finally done yet excited cell inators
because Selena Gomez has just confirmed
new music is on the way dropping the pop
stars last album revival came out in
2015 and over the past couple years
she's done a bunch of collabs dabbling
in reggaeton and working with EDM
artists like marshmallow
[Music]
but till we get more scoop on s G's new
tunes we've got plenty to enjoy of her
on the big screen
her latest flick is a zombie comedy film
called the dead don't Dodds
flesh-eating zombies dumb joke it's
really really creepy she opened up to et
about working with the star-studded cast
particularly Bill Murray personality I
he has no idea who I am and he refuses
to call me Selina he basically calls me
Gomez so it's actually the best it's the
best part of working without actually so
what do you thinking I'm thinking
zombies what new movies new music you'd
think Selena's calendar couldn't
possibly handle any more but that's just
not the case the 26 year old singer is
never too busy to give back well calling
Jason and a few of the other guys they
created this 10 years ago and it started
off really small it was all to get back
to where they're from in the hospital
that they actually went to so it's a
great cause and it's great people behind
it and you get to see these kids light
up and we get to go and make them laugh
and raise all this money for them and
they just feel so seen and important
that's gonna always be a part of my
dialogue for as long as I live I love
being a part of things
[Music]